my husband is in grad school um but he
just accept a job which a
$30,000 sign on bonus um that we'll get
next week even though he doesn't
graduate until August of
2024 and so we're not sure how we should
use it and so how much debt have you got
we have 155 right now and he's going to
be making what
250 uh 210 starting good what what does
it cost you a month to live right now
our rent is
1,400 probably around like 1,800 a month
yeah let's call it
3,000 okay okay I want you to live on
that when he's making
210 okay and you'll be debt free in a
year and would renting be the best
option right out of graduating you do
not need to buy a house you're
broke okay you're in debt up to your
eyeballs you and you don't need to buy a
car and you don't need to go on vacation